pocos minutos después de las 10 de la
mañana comenzaba oficialmente la
vacunación en este centro en el que nos
encontramos en el centro de santiago la
comuna de providencia sin embargo la
jornada comenzó un poco antes a las ocho
y media el presidente sebastián piñera
inauguraba este proceso masivo de
vacunación tras la llegada de cuatro
millones de dosis de la vacuna
sinovac la semana pasada es lo hizo en
la región de los lagos en el sub centro
del país una de las más afectadas por
las altas tasas de kobe en este momento
en total son más de 1.400 los lugares
habilitados para esta vacunación en las
345 comunas en las que se dividen las 16
regiones del país no se siente haber
sido la primera
super bien soy feliz y le deseo muchas
gracias y una gran bendición a todas las
gentes a los doctores a las enfermeras
que se han sacrificado tanto por
nosotros me vino muy temprano para
repetir llegué a que a las ocho y media
fue la primera en llegar
no esta complicación a semana
se siente fantástico
tranquila límite en esta etapa
el móvil de la pandemia como le afecta
muy vídeo no es cuentos ambiente pero ha
sido difícil como vemos el proceso de
vacunación continúa en este centro de
santiago centro de la comuna de
providencia donde decenas de personas
todos mayores de 90 años se han acercado
para recibir su primera dosis de vacuna
en un día histórico para todos el según
el ritmo que se ha planteado el gobierno
como objetivo se tendrán que vacunar a
100 mil personas diarias para lograr el
objetivo de vacunar a 5 millones de la
población más vulnerable en los tres
primeros meses de este 2010
se trata de todos los trabajadores de la
salud trabajadores en prácticas clínicas
aquellos alumnos que están en prácticas
residentes y funcionarios de las
residencias de ancianos trabajadores y
también residentes de los orfanatos de
la red pública y también todos los
adultos mayores del país el plan es
todavía más ambicioso para los primeros
seis meses del año en el que el gobierno
de chile tiene el objetivo de vacunar a
toda la población elegible en recibir la
vacuna estos serían
a más de 15 millones de los 19 millones
de chilenos